let me ask you a question so
if the roi is so low and it's not really
a good use of a man's time
um i mean i always tell guys in their
20s i always have guys call in on the
on these shows or ask questions when
they're younger and they're like i've
got a girlfriend or i'm living with a
girl that's four years older than i am
and i'm 24 and it's like oh
[ __ ] here we go why aren't you listening
to me um
i always tell guys don't get into
long-term related long-term monogamous
live with a czech type of relationships
in their 20s
like what's your view on that like is
there a time where they might want to
consider
chasing some women maybe in their 30s
and their 40s what it's not an issue of
chasing it's what
the right one comes along yeah it's
whether the right one comes along and
where you are in your life
um the girl i've been with now uh
i i threw in the towel uh i was dating
several girls at the time my
my current girlfriend included and um
it's just this one gal who like uh maybe
you know it
and and just uh you know ghosted me
and uh didn't see her for like two weeks
and also and she's banging at my door at
3am because her friend found out that i
wasn't gonna like
pursue that and she was banging her ex
boyfriend the point is uh
she's banging at my door you know i i'm
yelling at her it's late at night
and uh she you know like oh i'm never
gonna you know you're i knew you're a
player
and this is a girl who's like banging
some other guy i'm like well don't worry
about it never want to sleep with you
again and she punches me
and i'm like why am i doing this
and then i had i had the girlfriend i
got no who was nice
uh you know uh not not drop dead
gorgeous but good-looking enough
and she has a career uh has her act
together and she'll
she would show up on time and she would
make food
and i think afterwards please are we
fetus and efforts i don't mind well and
that was another thing this gal's like
you just like that
she she knew hoes because i was i was a
[ __ ] richard i was dating her i was
like
you just like that girl because she
cooks for you and treats you nice it's
like
yeah yeah yeah imagine that
what's the problem right give it a try
sometimes sweetheart
yeah but inevitably i i just you run on
energy and um if you got the right gal
there at that point in time it's like
cool you know just uh
but i hate to say it but she's not the
number one thing in my life i mean i
guess my life is my own life and that's
the number one thing but it was kind of
a
like i'm gonna go this way do you want
to come with
um she's a great she is a great girl
she's a great wonderful woman
uh but i i could see it where you you
tap out
and you either have a girl that you want
to get serious with
or not and you just go on and live your
life but
you know the days of going to a
nightclub or i am never swiping
on an effing dating app i'm never going
on a dating app
that's over and so i can understand
where men just like throw in the towel
they're done and uh maybe they settle
down but
um that presumes there's a high quality
woman there
yeah i mean there's a lot to break down
on that i've i was i was thinking about
this a few days ago about about putting
something
in in depth together you know for guys
in their teens 20s 30s you know minimum
to kind of at least give them a little
bit of a road map and in greater depth
you know beyond like a 10-minute video
but
um yeah the the the chasing a tail is
not a good idea
you